all right I love the media I mean I love
the media check out these old headlines
Trump promises 4% growth economists say
no way or this one if Trump thinks he
can get more than three percent economic
growth he's dreaming and last but not
least hello Larry if you use the
standard of what the administration has
held out the hope for three to four
percent growth there is nothing in any
data suggesting that we're moving
towards that three to four percent
growth stammers oh yeah well eat this
Larry I am thrilled to announce that in
the second quarter of this year the
United States economy grew at the
amazing rate of 4.1%
so who could have predicted that I
believe it's time to establish a
national goal of reaching 4 percent
economic growth my great economists
don't want me to say this but I think we
can do better than that
the optimist I wish I could find the
right sentiment to express how I feel I
[Music]
wish I could remember what I was
laughing at but so it's Trump proves the
naysayers wrong what are the naysayers
clinging to a little piece of leaked
audio this is the kind of the ugly
sordid stuff that happens behind the
scenes at a campaign well at least at
this Trump campaign that we're now
hearing about well this tape does show
how the sausage is made and you really
never want a new hobby I'm here in to
criminal co-conspirators conspiring on
making a payment the President of the
United States tried to tell you what
you're seeing and what you're reading is
not happening don't believe what you see
with our own ears
don't believe what you see with your own
ears that's like a fortune cookie that
makes no sense in other words it's a
fortune cookie dumb question did anyone
die from this secret conversation with
anyone physically hurt does anyone care
which leads me to a new segment does
anyone care all right tonight's episode
a slimy lawyer secretly tapes his client
referring to hush money paid to a
centerfold who had consensual relations
with a rich dude who later became our
president I know what you're thinking
where is the honour among playmates
granted it's not the sort of deal most
of us will make in our lives but Trump
paying a centerfold to keep quiet I
believe that's called Tuesday petty cash
for playmates - Trump that's his swear
jar in fact I wouldn't be surprised if
there are more you're 73 a billionaire
thrice-married living in Manhattan and
you don't have to share your apartment
you're hanging around models if you only
slept with stormy Daniels and this other
playmate you might be gay
and if he is I still don't care you know
what I care about I care about those new
Atkins shakes I love them they're
delicious zzzquil I wonder sometimes if
I love that too much and world peace
what's not to love
those things matter to me Trump's love
life that's not on my list but now I
realized that it matters for example
right now in North Korea they're
dismantling rocket science why obviously
because Trump may have slept around the
Europeans just stopped scamming us with
tariffs but according to CNN before that
Trump may have slept around the GDP for
this quarter just said four point one
percent and to celebrate us steal just
reopened a plant in Illinois but
according to sources before that
happened
Trump slept around we scrapped 3,000
useless regulations we created an
economic boom but Trump slept around so
wait a second I sense a trend here
what's at what experts call a
correlation here are all these amazing
achievements and right before them Trump
had sexual relations with women could it
be that all of this good news is due to
that I know I know correlation isn't
causation but maybe a sex life has made
us all much better off I do feel bad for
the media they invest so much time in
these scandals why because Democrats are
hopeless at understanding sex raising
income taxes is their pillow talk
redistribution is their foreplay that's
why they're really good at screwing
people
which is why thank you very much which
is why all this good news the Dems would
rather get drunk on tawdry tales and
they think you should too because oh my
god
he lied oh come on whether we know it
happened or not whether the payment
happen or not what we know is that he
lied shows Trump lying once again what
else is new there the White House lied
about it when when this first came out
hope Hicks said that Donald Trump knew
nothing about this payment he's actually
saying the president had no knowledge
you know and Giuliani knows that is a
flat-out lie he had an affair with her
oh my god he lied he lied about an
affair how is this surprising accusing a
rich old New Yorker of lying about an
affair
it's like accusing Michael Moore of
splitting his pants it's to be expected
and I hate to tell you this is why lying
was invented do you remember the first
lie the Garden of Eden that snake oh no
no he's just a friend as long as their
sex there will be lies and as long as
there are lies
there will be journalism in politics I
don't condone it but when there's so
much good stuff happening in this world
I just don't care
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight yes like a man who
steals your organs to sell on the black
market he'll keep you in stitches actor
writer and comedian Jaime LaSalle he
produces more drama than my pet llama he
stars in the new movie got snail out
this fall actor Nick
Searcy social interaction gives her
allergic reactions natural review
reporter Kat Tim the Jumbotron is his
iPhone former WWE superstar and my
massive sidekick Tyrus
you're gonna get me oh oh yeah
I'm scared I'm shaking in my little
boots you Jamie how you doing what are
your thoughts on this week so far any
insight man I wouldn't have believed
that story if I hadn't heard it with my
own eyes just unbelievable and I feel
like that parrot joke that was brutal
right the parrot was not only missing a
mirror and a ladder he was missing a
punch line and timing but don't you
think like storming down it's just weird
that it's it's literally like they used
one of those porn star name generators
mm-hmm take him up it's like Oh what's
your favorite weather and your favorite
drink
stormy Daniels yes like mine would be
rainy martini yours might be sunshine
Sauvignon that was an insult I believe
yes I believe all right Nick
what do you make of uh what do you make
of the good news and the scandals pick
one whatever you want
well the scandals remote you know it
reminds me of the movie I directed
Gosnell which is coming out October 12th
I should go see it obvious yes my movie
has lawyers in it that's might reminded
me of that but the thing about the
lawyers is like well the taping thing
that the the tape of Trump talking to
his lawyer is that like common practice
to do lawyers tape their clients and if
so why yeah that's the thing that I
don't get yeah God knows and it's so
funny that like Trump's lawyer who's a
fixer hires Hillary's lawyer who's a
fixer Lanny Davis which would be like
Lanny Davis hiring Michael Cohen
they're like fixers hiring fixers I need
a fixer no what are you doing later oh
well I thought you have an idea
cat thoughts I can't even begin to tell
you just how little I care who anyone
has sex with I don't care and I think
that everyone in the media they really
think that if they can prove that Donald
Trump had
sex with these women and lied about it
the people who support Trump are going
to suddenly stop supporting exactly but
I think that people care more about
things like the economy and they care
more about them having more money in
their pockets it's not that they don't
believe it it's not that they're stupid
is that it just doesn't really matter
you know how much I've been affected by
who Donald Trump has had sex with not at
all really yeah like my day has been
pretty much the same as it would have
been if he wouldn't have had sex with
all those people mm-hmm I think yeah I
think you're right and it's actually the
achievements that affect your life not
what he's been doing on this private
time elsewhere tyrus bring it home
thoughts with them as far as lying I'm
you know I'm not really gonna judge the
president if he's lying or not because
I've been known to lie about whether I
take the trash out or not so what do you
guys call it white lies yeah that's like
my thing
so I just feel like we talked about it
before they love the scary movie
yeah and it's coming to theaters it just
never comes to theaters even recording
somebody is shameful and Cohen I mean
damn bruh like ya can't get much lower
than just being a rat and trying to set
up someone who takes care of you and
your family but what kills me is that he
is setting somebody up while he's
supposed to be a fixer he's a nun like
he's literally he's one of the worst
people in the world if you think about
somebody that's so rotten yeah that you
would trust him with your secrets and he
records them and then when he gets in
trouble he tries to use them against you
and then I guess he was sitting on the
phone why he was recording so you
couldn't even really make out what he's
saying then I get like a epidemiologist
and a rocket surgeon to figure out
whether he said cash or cheque like it's
literally the worst he's a really bad
blackmailer yeah yeah yeah and then he
finds out that it's a dis bärbel offense
yeah Kord a client yes actually against
the law so he broke a law there then he
leaked information whether I know that
who happened what thinking the
prosecution was gonna help him they're
like but no we're not gonna help you at
all it's can't cooperate anything
because you're a proven liar like he
literally had the worst week that a
villain usually villains have bad weeks
at the end of the
this dude started out with like here's
my plan like he got arrested like
literally is the worst
these are worst villain I've ever seen
like you would think he'd be better yet
I got to close it out but I think what
drives me nuts is I'm when you watch the
other networks there it's a cat's point
they're ignoring what matters in in in
their snow globe the only thing that
matters porn stars playmates Cohn and
tape that's in their snow globe and they
act when you're in a snow globe you
don't no you're not you're in one right
so you just think this is your world
meanwhile everybody else in the world is
is is enjoying basically their life is
getting marginally better every day but
they don't know that in CNN because
they're too busy chasing tail or tails
tawdry tales